now to the other end of Pennsylvania
Avenue the White House trade advisor
Peter Navarro joining us now Peter good
morning to you thanks for being here
good morning never heard that the other
end of Pennsylvania Avenue that's good
well here we go today you're on the
screen now three points 3.3 million
people filing for those jobless claims
that is a new record Peter as our
economy has come to a near standstill
what is the White House reaction to that
this morning this is to be totally
expected because the whole strategy of
President Trump is to basically get
social distancing so we can combat the
virus we put public health above
economics in the very very short run so
this is no surprise this is this is
expected and we should accept the news
because we're doing what we need to do
to combat the virus Andrew and and seize
the markets we just got we just got two
trillion dollars worth of stimulus and
it's four points of the compass we're a
targeted relief particularly for the
low-income workers we've got a big
fiscal stimulus itself
we've got targeted industry relief and
we've got a liquidity piece to it which
is unprecedented in history so President
Trump and his team doing everything we
possibly can to deal both with the
public health emergency and the economic
crisis we just have to be like the
British I guess in World War two a
little stiff upper lip and and and fight
this virus so let's dig into some of
what you just said the Dow seems to be
accepting what it is seeing it's up 731
points right now but first to the
American worker as we see 3.3 million
people in a week filing for jobless
claims you understand the pain that so
many Americans are in right now so
nobody understands the founder sander
nobody understands they're paying more
than this White House this is a
president who has transformed the
Republican Party into the party of the
working class and I spent every day
trying to help Americans who work with
their hands so we are we are we are
attuned to their plight and we're going
to try to get them that cash cushion as
soon as possible we're gonna try to get
some window open for small businesses
and and we look it's it's Trump time
here as rapidly as possible we're going
to do this what we've been waiting for
us is for Congress to do their thing and
we're still waiting right to that point
we understand that there will be a vote
in the house tomorrow but the Senate
supported this it's two trillion dollars
as far as the checks are concerned we
hear such varied estimates about when
the American people that will be getting
those checks will actually get them
we've heard a week we've heard 15 days
we've heard three weeks when will people
get those checks Peter I it's not my
lane Sandra and they will we'll know
that later in the day you have secretary
minutes you know what I'm trying to do
Sandra is to make sure our supply chain
for the protective gear that our health
care workers need the gloves the mask
the goggles the ventilators are moving
briskly into places like New York City
in New Orleans in Detroit and places
like that and so that's what I'm
consumed with 24/7 and working with FEMA
working with HHS we are fully engaged in
that process and we're working double
time we got planes in the air we got
FedEx planes we got FEMA planes we got
military planes we have the full force
full force of the American government
but we also have the full force of
private enterprise and that's what we're
doing here and that's what I'm focused
on and we're gonna well we're going to
get those checks to the people as
quickly as possible I'm sure that the
Treasury Department right behind me is
is already getting ready to do that okay
on that note when you look at some of
the key parts of the cares that Act
you're talking about that two trillion
dollar relief package 500 billion for
hard-hit industries of which you are
talking about 377 billion for the small
business aid and back to your point the
priority the medical side of things
right now those on the frontlines in our
hospitals a hundred billion dollars for
Hospital
how will that money be used accounted
for as Peter we've referenced the New
York Post cover this morning a nurse
covered in garbage bags because they're
running out of hospital gowns how do we
make sure that those dollars are spent
appropriately and get into the hands of
those people that need them the most
well the dollars don't mean anything
unless they're converted into things
like personal protective equipment and
they have to cover the hospitals or
tremendous surge now particularly in New
York City
they've got bills to pay things to buy
and that's how that money's going to be
used okay I want to dig a little bit
further into how some of the industries
will be affected there's some reporting
in The Wall Street Journal this morning
that Steve minuchin the Treasury
secretary is is coming up with some sort
of plan to take a stake in u.s. Airlines
and return for grants can you confirm
that that is a possibility I can't
confirm or deny that again this is not
my lane things are moving very rapidly
that Secretary of minuchin Lane it's not
unprecedented to have the federal
government take equity shares and
companies that was done in some years
ago but let's let's see what happens all
right I suggest that you have secretary
minuchin or like head low on well
they're a little busy negotiating the
biggest package for the American people
and the history of the world so forgive
that I'm here and and I have to
emphasize that my role in this in this
crisis is to help HHS and FEMA and and
hospitals around the country get what
they need and we're just we're just
getting that done so on that note how
would you how would you characterize the
progress that you are making on that
front as so badly you're hearing from
the New York governor we might hear from
him in a little bit he has been taking
on about this time every single day to
say that they're not going
the ventilators that they need send him
his way so what update can you give us
on that if that is very specifically
your lane this morning just just a day
or so ago when he was talking about not
getting the ventilators he needed that
that morning FEMA had sent 2,000
additional ventilators in that afternoon
there were a 2,000 additional
ventilators sent in my office personally
had had shepherded 400 ventilators the
day before and there will be more to
follow we're sending I see may has an
update now we're sending half a million
gloves thousands hundreds and thousands
of face Mac's Oh Sandra these are great
questions you're asking what I can tell
you is that we're we're jamming the
channel as fast as we can we know that
New York is not not only a hot spot but
it the the hospital system there is is
is overburdened now because of this
surge and we're we're basically sending
everything we can to help but we've also
got an emerging problem in in New
Orleans
we've got Detroit we've got Chicago
Seattle
California my home state like I said
there's there's planes in the air
everywhere now and and we're as we speak
we're we're gearing up but let me tell
you another kind of thing which I think
is should be heartening to the American
people what I've been doing is working
with private industry to repurpose some
of their factories so for example the
National Council of textile organization
which includes companies like Hanes
Fruit of the Loom Parkdale Mills
as we speak they have repurposed some of
their garment factories in to making
masks and those things are going to
start churning off to the assembly line
by the millions per week
Honeywell we were able to fast-track a
new plant in Smithfield Rhode Island for
the things that are gold which or the
n95 mask and that's going to be ramping
up quickly we've had General Dynamics I
called Phoebe novakovic they are the CEO
over the weekend and said Phoebe
give us whatever you got in inventory of
whatever you have for equipment and she
mobilized their team and yesterday we
delivered 4,500 Tyvek seat suits which
again for health care workers those are
gold a couple of thousand kimberly-clark
a series suits and we're just and and
this is what's happening here I I
couldn't be prouder of America right now
I couldn't be prouder of the federal
government and private enterprise and
President Trump for bringing that effort
together because every time I call
something if I call a thousand people
today 9999 of them in the private sector
will be more than willing to do whatever
we ask whatever we ask and I know that
delicate balance and there's going to be
that delicate balance you already hear
the president talking about wanting to
reopen aspects of the economy while
we're still battling on the front lines
this disease that is going to be the
story of going forward we'd love to
check back in with you soon Peter
Navarro it's always a pleasure senator
bye-bye